This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We begin with an unsolved murder mystery. Actually a series of unsolved murders. Perhaps the work of the United States first serial killer. Before Jack the Ripper terrorized London, before H.H. Holmes stocked the Chicago World's Fair, Austin, Texas, was haunted by the servant girl, a narrator.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们从一起未解的谋杀悬案说起。实际上是一系列未解的谋杀案。这可能是美国第一位连环杀手的作品。在“开膛手杰克”恐吓伦敦之前，在H.H.福尔摩斯在芝加哥世博会作案之前，德克萨斯州的奥斯汀曾被一位“女仆杀手”所困扰。
Producer Avery Truffman would like to reiterate that these murders are unsolved. So, it's possible that these were individual murders rather than the work of one man. The hard-fast fact is this. In 1885, eight women, mostly black servants, were brutally murdered in the dark of night. And the night was very dark in Austin in 1885. There was essentially no street lighting. The darkness of just life after sundown in the 19th century is something that modern people are just completely unfamiliar with. This is Bruce Hunt. He's an associate professor of the history of physics and technology at the University
制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼想重申，这些谋杀案至今未破。因此，这些谋杀案可能是独立的个体案件，而非出自同一人之手。一个铁一般的事实是：1885年，八名女性，主要是黑人女仆，在深夜惨遭杀害。1885年的奥斯汀，夜晚非常黑暗。基本上没有路灯。19世纪日落后那种纯粹的黑暗，是现代人完全无法想象的。这位是布鲁斯·亨特。他是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校物理与技术史副教授。
of Texas, Austin. Basically, there was no outdoor lighting. There was moonlight. When the moon was out, that was about it. And in 1894, the city of Austin decided to buy more moonlight in the form of towers. They're called moonlight towers because they were supposed to approximate a full moon. Austin adopted moonlight towers, which really worked towers. There were 15 stories high, very industrial looking, made of metal scaffolding, and each was crowned with a circle of six lights, soaring way, way high above the city.
基本上，那时没有户外照明。只有月光。月亮出来时，也就仅此而已。1894年，奥斯汀市决定通过“塔楼”来购买更多的月光。它们被称为“月光塔”，因为它们旨在模拟满月。奥斯汀采用了月光塔，这确实起到了作用。它们有15层楼高，看起来非常工业化，由金属脚手架制成，每座塔顶都环绕着六盏灯，高高地耸立在城市上空。
Austin wasn't the first to implement tower lighting. In the 1800s a lot of major cities had them. Arc-like towers illuminated streets in New York, Baltimore, LA, San Jose, and Detroit. Detroit had a very huge system of much larger than Austin ever had. And that's actually where Austin got their Moonlight Towers. In 1894 the city purchased 31 of them from the city of Detroit. And despite their romantic name, the absurdly tall moonlight towers were actually a very practical design. They're not meant to look cool, they're very functional.
奥斯汀并不是第一个实施塔式照明的城市。在19世纪，许多大城市都有这种塔。弧光灯塔照亮了纽约、巴尔的摩、洛杉矶、圣何塞和底特律的街道。底特律拥有一个比奥斯汀大得多的系统。而这正是奥斯汀获得月光塔的地方。1894年，该市从底特律购买了31座塔。尽管名字浪漫，但这些高得离谱的月光塔实际上是一种非常实用的设计。它们不是为了看起来酷，而是非常实用。
And their height was meant to accommodate the lighting they used. They're arc lights, they were initially arc lights. Carbon arc lights, the precursor to the incandescent bulb. Arc lights are basically a continued spark between two carbon electrodes. They're extremely bright. A lot of glare. They're the sort of thing you use in a search light. And if you put arc lights at street level, that's blinding.
它们的高度是为了适应所使用的照明设备。它们是弧光灯，最初是弧光灯。碳弧灯，白炽灯的前身。弧光灯本质上是两个碳电极之间持续的火花。它们极其明亮，眩光严重。它们是你会在探照灯中使用的那种东西。如果你把弧光灯放在街道高度，那会让人眼花缭乱。
Well, the solution to that was to put it up high enough that you'd spread the light out. But even on their high tower, the arc lights were still so bright. I mean, they'd be bright by today's standards, but then imagine what that would look like to you. If you were an austenite in the 1890s, a custom-coupich black streets and gas lamps. A gas lamp has the power of about 15 candles, and arc light has the power of a couple thousand.
好吧，解决办法是把它放得足够高，这样光线就能散开。但即使在这么高的塔上，弧光灯依然非常明亮。我的意思是，以今天的标准来看它们都很亮，但想象一下1890年代的奥斯汀人会怎么看。当时习惯了昏暗的街道和煤气灯。煤气灯的亮度大约相当于15支蜡烛，而弧光灯的亮度相当于几千支。
It was a very intense light, almost two months' light. People would go out and enjoy the light, but they would bring umbrellas in order to shield themselves from the glare. This is Ernest Freberg, head of the history department at the University of Tennessee Knoxville. He's also the author of the book The Age of Edison, Electric Light and the invention of modern America. And the glare was just one of the problems with our glights. There were a few other downsides. One was that it sounded like a swarm of angry bees. It would buzz and they would a swarm of angry bees. It would buzz and they would, as these carbons burned, they would drop shreds of ash burning ash down on people down below. So there's a drawback.
那是一种非常强烈的光，几乎是两个月的月光。人们会出去享受这种光，但他们会带上雨伞来遮挡眩光。这位是欧内斯特·弗雷伯格，田纳西大学诺克斯维尔分校历史系主任。他也是《爱迪生时代：电灯与现代美国的发明》一书的作者。眩光只是弧光灯的问题之一。还有其他一些缺点。一个是它听起来像一群愤怒的蜜蜂。它会嗡嗡作响，随着碳棒燃烧，它们会掉落燃烧的灰烬，落在下面的人身上。所以这是一个缺点。
Even with their blinding glare and nefarious hum and deposits of molten ash, carbon arc lights were still so exciting. They created a whole new world for people accustomed to dim and dark cities. Because bright electric light can highlight certain things that you might not even notice in the full light of day. So it was a lot of great discussion about seeing the grass in a totally different way. People loved to look at their hands under the arc light in the dark and they were seeing the details of their hands in new ways. Duh-huuur. So it was really a change in perception that was thrilling and also the thrilling feeling of being out at night
尽管有刺眼的眩光、讨厌的嗡嗡声和熔化的灰烬沉积，碳弧灯仍然非常令人兴奋。它们为习惯了昏暗城市的人们创造了一个全新的世界。因为明亮的电灯可以突出某些你在白天完全光线下可能根本注意不到的东西。所以当时有很多关于以完全不同的方式观察草地的讨论。人们喜欢在黑暗中看着弧光灯下的手，他们以新的方式看到了手的细节。所以这确实是一种令人兴奋的感知变化，同时也有一种在夜间外出并感到安全的刺激感，
and feeling safe because visibility equals safety. Some cities thought that these new fangled streetlights were gonna cut back on the need for police or even eliminate law enforcement entirely. If you could set up an arc light in the middle of a town square, you'd sort of be returning the square to the public and take it away from criminals and nared wells who were hanging around in the shadows by driving out the shadows.
因为可见度等于安全。一些城市认为这些新奇的路灯将减少对警察的需求，甚至完全消除执法。如果你能在城镇广场中央安装一盏弧光灯，你就能把广场还给公众，通过驱散阴影，把那些徘徊在阴影中的罪犯和不法之徒赶走。
People called the arc lights policemen on a pole and they allowed for a whole new kind of nightlife. Many people were very excited to go out and attend a fancy ball under the arc light. But once they got there, they realized that this harsh blue light highlighted every one of their imperfections. So every gray hair and wrinkle, many people found that they would never again go near electric light. Vanity aside, everyone was kind of nervous about the general idea of light at night.
人们称弧光灯为“杆子上的警察”，它们催生了一种全新的夜生活。许多人非常兴奋地出去参加弧光灯下的高级舞会。但一旦到了那里，他们意识到这种刺眼的蓝光突显了他们每一个瑕疵。所以每一根白发和皱纹，许多人发现他们再也不会靠近电灯了。抛开虚荣心不谈，每个人都对夜间照明的普遍想法感到有些紧张。
Twas unnatural, they decreed, the towers could cause sleeplessness, cast eerie shadows, crops would overproduce, hens would overlay. There were stories that the arc lights lured restless alligators to the shore and attracted biblical proportions of crickets, according to the Austin statesman in 1921. Egypt has nothing on central Texas when it comes to scourges. After the recent flood came the crickets, tempted by the beams of light to settle in illuminated vicinity. Bruce Hunt suspects that these reports were overblown.
他们断言，这不自然，塔楼会导致失眠，投下怪异的阴影，农作物会过度生长，母鸡会过度产蛋。据1921年的《奥斯汀政治家报》报道，有传言称弧光灯将不安分的短吻鳄引诱到岸边，并吸引了圣经规模的蟋蟀。在灾祸方面，埃及根本比不上德克萨斯中部。最近的洪水过后，蟋蟀来了，被光束吸引，定居在照明区域。布鲁斯·亨特怀疑这些报道被夸大了。
Eh, you know, I think a lot of that was kind of newspaperman joking around. Oh, journalism was so much fun back then. But the biggest problem with the towers was that their height made them a drag to maintain. The arcs burned down the carbon electrodes very rapidly, so you had to go up and change them about once a day. And I cannot emphasize enough how super tall these things are, as tall as a 15 story building. And if you look at one of Austin's moonlight towers, there's a rickety little pulley-type thing in the center of it.
呃，你知道，我认为其中很多只是报社记者的玩笑。哦，那时候的新闻业太有趣了。但塔楼最大的问题是它们的高度使得维护起来很麻烦。电弧会非常迅速地烧掉碳电极，所以你必须每天上去更换一次。我怎么强调都不为过，这些东西超级高，和15层楼一样高。如果你看奥斯汀的月光塔，中心有一个摇摇欲坠的小滑轮装置。
It's like a dumb-waiter apparatus. Supposedly the guy would stand on that and pull himself up to go up and change the carbon electrodes every day. That's a nuisance and an expense. And so as soon as they could, really, by the 1920s, the city replaced the art lights, the carbon arcs, with big, incandescent bulbs, which were not as bright, but were a lot easier to maintain. But while Austin was fudging around with different bulbs, most other cities had already removed their tower lights completely. Every place also banned them by about the 1920s, but Austin kept them.
就像一个送菜电梯。据说那个人会站在上面，把自己拉上去，每天去更换碳电极。这既麻烦又昂贵。所以一旦可能，到1920年代，该市就用大型白炽灯取代了弧光灯，虽然亮度不如弧光灯，但维护起来容易得多。但在奥斯汀折腾不同灯泡的同时，大多数其他城市已经完全拆除了他们的塔灯。到1920年代左右，每个地方也都禁止了它们，但奥斯汀保留了下来。
Austin had fallen on hard times, and the city couldn't afford to tear down the towers. And so they just stayed. Into this day, 17 of the original 31 survived. The last of the Moonlight Towers. Although today, without the arc lights, the Moonlight Towers have a kind of weak and distant glow. They're easy to ignore, but you might know them from a little movie called Dazed and Confused. Dazed and Confused is set in Austin in 1976.
奥斯汀陷入了困境，城市负担不起拆除塔楼的费用。所以它们就留了下来。直到今天，最初的31座塔中幸存下来了17座。最后的月光塔。虽然今天没有了弧光灯，月光塔发出一种微弱而遥远的光芒。它们很容易被忽视，但你可能从一部叫《年少轻狂》的小电影中知道它们。《年少轻狂》的故事背景设定在1976年的奥斯汀。
In the movie, a bunch of kids party and drive around until they all gather at the end by a moonlight tower. There's a new fist in the making as we speak. It's out of the moon moon town. In the movie Dazing could use a Richard Lake later movie Matthew McConaughey says party at the moon tower, but they're moonlight towers. In real life people don't actually go there to party. Most of them are just in sort of like parking lots or something. I went to a moonlight tower on the side of a busy road on the corner of ninth and Guadalupe. It's not Guadalupe, it's Guadalupe.
在电影中，一群孩子聚会并开车四处游荡，直到最后聚集在月光塔旁。正如我们所说，一个新的拳头正在形成。它就在月光塔外。在理查德·林克莱特的电影《年少轻狂》中，马修·麦康纳说“在月光塔聚会”，但它们是“月光塔”。在现实生活中，人们实际上并不会去那里聚会。它们大多数只是在停车场之类的地方。我去了第九街和瓜达卢佩街拐角处路边的一座月光塔。不是瓜达卢佩，是瓜达卢佩。
Clearly, I needed a local's help. My name is Wiley Wiggins, I'm 38 years old, I was born and raised in Austin, Texas, and in the early 90s I was in a movie by a Richard Linklater called Dazed and Confused. He played the freshman Mitch Kramer, who wonders about the Moon Towers. What's it called the Moon couple though. In real life these Moonlight Towers would be really hard to climb, which is why for this scene, Richard Linklider made a fake Moonlight Tower. The one in the movie had a ladder, not the pulley thing, and it was nowhere near as tall
显然，我需要当地人的帮助。我叫威利·威金斯，今年38岁，我在德克萨斯州奥斯汀出生长大，90年代初我出演了理查德·林克莱特的一部电影《年少轻狂》。他扮演了大一新生米奇·克莱默，他对月光塔感到好奇。它叫什么月光塔。在现实生活中，这些月光塔真的很难爬，这就是为什么在这一幕中，理查德·林克莱特制作了一个假的月光塔。电影里的那个有梯子，不是滑轮装置，而且高度远不及
as a real Moonlight Tower. And I'm terrified of heights. Wily would have never tried this stunt. No one he knew actually did. When I was a kid, there was always somebody who knew somebody who knew somebody who had climbed it. It's unclear how many times this was ever attempted, but in any case, stories abound. And there was a point when Austin considered finally taking these old lights down, just
真正的月光塔。而且我有恐高症。威利永远不会尝试这种特技。他认识的人中也没有人真的做过。当我还是个孩子的时候，总有人认识某个人，那个人认识某个人爬过它。不清楚这种情况尝试过多少次，但无论如何，故事比比皆是。有一次，奥斯汀考虑最终拆除这些旧灯，就像
like all the other cities had done. In the 50s and 60s, the attitude was, well, these are out of date, and we pull those down. In fact, I've got a video I found online that was a sort of little historical vignettes of Austin that was made by one of local TD stations in the 1960s. Tonight, progress report Austin presents the Legends of Austin. And is it? Here's the Moonlight Towers, and here they show... Now, they're out of date now and no doubt will soon disappear. Modern times and new improvements in lighting have made these inefficient for providing light to our city of night.
所有其他城市所做的那样。在50和60年代，人们的态度是，好吧，这些已经过时了，我们把它们拆掉。事实上，我在网上找到了一段视频，是当地电视台在1960年代制作的关于奥斯汀的小历史片段。今晚，进度报告奥斯汀呈现奥斯汀的传说。是这样吗？这是月光塔，在这里他们展示……现在，它们已经过时了，毫无疑问很快就会消失。现代和照明的新改进使得它们在为我们的城市提供夜间照明方面效率低下。
And it's a shame for anyone who has walked into their glow in a fall evening watching the shadows around him, knows the beauty they have provided. And there's that sort of tone that that's well and a little remnant of our past that we will lose soon. Well, people just said why should we lose it? Keep them up. So the towers were inducted into the National Registry of Historic Places in 1976. Some of the towers even have plaques.
对于任何在秋夜走进它们光芒中，看着周围阴影的人来说，这是一种遗憾，他们知道它们所提供的美。有一种语气是，这只是我们过去的一点残余，我们很快就会失去。好吧，人们只是说为什么要失去它？保留它们。所以这些塔在1976年被列入国家史迹名录。有些塔甚至还有牌匾。
And Austin's power provider, Austin Energy, funnels a lot of resources into maintaining the towers. Take it from Austin Energy Spokesman, Carlos Cordova. Right now it's really interesting about the Moonlight towers. Is there going to be going through a renovation? And this renovation is a total drag because these towers are in the national registry of historic places.
奥斯汀的电力供应商奥斯汀能源公司投入了大量资源来维护这些塔楼。听听奥斯汀能源公司发言人卡洛斯·科尔多瓦怎么说。现在关于月光塔的事情真的很有趣。它们要进行翻新吗？这次翻新非常麻烦，因为这些塔在国家史迹名录中。
They have to be restored to their original form, so we can't go to Home Depot or Lowe's and buy bolts and nuts. The contractor has to cast bolts and parts that look exactly identical to the original, so you can keep its historic designation. That's what I love about these moonlight towers, man. I get older. They stay the same age. I'm an expensive project, isn't it? Yes, it's very specialized work that, of of course affects the price, but notice there wasn't
它们必须恢复到原来的形式，所以我们不能去家得宝或劳氏买螺栓和螺母。承包商必须铸造看起来与原件完全相同的螺栓和零件，这样才能保持其历史地位。这就是我喜欢这些月光塔的地方，伙计。我变老了，它们保持同样的年龄。这是一个昂贵的项目，不是吗？是的，这是非常专业的工作，当然会影响价格，但请注意，并没有
any uproar from the citizens about spending this penny on the Moonlight Towers. Ostenites are willing to put up the funds. The towers are this point of civic pride. Every year during the holidays, Austin Energy strings Christmas lights from the Moonlight Tower in Zilker Park, and Ostenites lovingly refer to that tower as the Zilker Park Tree. Austin also hosts the Moon Tower Comedy Festival and there's a local band called Moonlight Towers and at a restaurant I ordered a drink called a Moonlight Tower.
任何市民对在月光塔上花费这笔钱表示不满。奥斯汀人愿意提供资金。这些塔是公民自豪感的象征。每年假期期间，奥斯汀能源公司都会从齐尔克公园的月光塔上串起圣诞灯，奥斯汀人亲切地称那座塔为“齐尔克公园树”。奥斯汀还举办月光塔喜剧节，当地有一个乐队叫“月光塔”，在一家餐馆里，我点了一杯叫“月光塔”的饮料。
The towers have become part of the character and folklore of Austin. I mean there's all sorts of legends and stuff about them. When I was a kid of course there was always a legend that somebody had climbed up on acid and fallen off and died which is evidently not true. But then of course, the other legend is that they were built because of, there was a serial killer, like in the, what, like the 1800s. And that one, I think, is supposed to be true, right? Have we, have we verified this? The Serving Girl Annihilator story is not a myth at all they absolutely true it has nothing to do with the moonlight towers at least not directly that
这些塔已经成为奥斯汀性格和民间传说的一部分。我的意思是，关于它们有各种各样的传说。当我还是个孩子的时候，当然总有一个传说，说有人吸了毒爬上去，摔下来死了，这显然不是真的。但当然，另一个传说是它们是因为1800年代有个连环杀手才建造的。那个，我想，应该是真的，对吧？我们核实过这个了吗？“女仆杀手”的故事根本不是神话，它是绝对真实的，它与月光塔无关，至少不是直接相关，那
was all over with well before they talk about the moonlight towers came up and I've never seen anything about a need for them being associated with a servant girl annihilator case still the servant girl annihilator became the genesis story that Austinites tell about these lights. And the story of the Servant Girl Annihilator does truly illustrate the limitations of 19th century nighttime. These carbon arc street lamps were chasing away darkness and fear.
一切在人们谈论月光塔之前就已经结束了，我从未见过任何关于它们与女仆杀手案有关的说法。尽管如此，“女仆杀手”还是成为了奥斯汀人讲述这些灯的起源故事。而“女仆杀手”的故事确实说明了19世纪夜间的局限性。这些碳弧路灯正在驱散黑暗和恐惧。
And I think it's something we so easily take for granted how liberating this is, how much the darkness was a permanent form of limitation on free will and human activity for us. I mean, it had great benefits, of course, that we sometimes miss because we have too much light now. Moonlight towers were a strange offshoot, a sort of knee-and-rathol in the evolution of the street light. And in Austin, where a keep Austin weird is an unofficial slogan of the city,
我认为我们太容易认为这是理所当然的，这是多么令人解放，黑暗在多大程度上是对我们自由意志和人类活动的永久限制。我的意思是，它当然有巨大的好处，我们有时会怀念它，因为我们现在有太多的光。月光塔是一个奇怪的产物，是路灯进化中的一种“尼安德特人”。而在奥斯汀，那里“保持奥斯汀怪异”是该市非官方的口号，
printed on bumper stickers and scrolled on bathroom walls, you can't help but feel like the moon towers are doing their part. After every other city has torn their towers down, Austin holds on to theirs and preserves them. A reminder of the time when the Texas capital was just an oddball little town that bought the moon. To those who haven't looked closely, look closely soon. For the day of the artificial moonlight is ending, and this sight will one day disappear
印在保险杠贴纸上，写在浴室墙壁上，你忍不住觉得月光塔正在尽自己的一份力量。在其他所有城市都拆除了它们的塔楼后，奥斯汀坚持保留并保护了它们的塔楼。提醒人们那个德克萨斯州首府只是一个购买了月亮的小镇的时代。对于那些还没有仔细观察的人，请尽快仔细观察。因为人造月光的日子即将结束，这个景象总有一天会从我们的城市中消失，
from our city. The last in our nation with the moonlight glow from such talents. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of KALW 91.7 San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, an architecture andiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Special thanks to Josephine Hill and Mark Oppenheimer for help on this episode. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars if you follow me in either one of those two places you can be aware of all the things and talks and events we have coming up, including a free public talk
我们国家最后一个拥有这种月光光芒的城市。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是KALW 91.7旧金山的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的Arxine建筑和室内设计公司办公室制作。特别感谢约瑟芬·希尔和马克·奥本海默对本集的帮助。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我在推特上叫罗曼·马尔斯，如果你关注我这两个地方中的任何一个，你就可以了解我们即将推出的所有事情、谈话和活动，包括一场免费的公开演讲，
that I'm giving in a middle school gym about two miles from my house. So excited about that one. Plus we have a cool Tumblr, a Spotify playlist for an Instagram, but I encourage you to explore the entire world of 99% admissible at 99pi.org. Radio Topea from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我将在离我家大约两英里的一所中学体育馆里进行演讲。对此我感到非常兴奋。此外，我们还有一个很酷的Tumblr、Spotify播放列表和Instagram，但我鼓励你在99pi.org探索《99%隐形》的整个世界。来自PRX的RadioTopia。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。